T
OF FOLKS WHO RAN THE RNC DIDN'T
HAVE, AND YOU DID IT.
THANKS.
WE COULD GUESS THIS BUT STILL
SHOCKING TO SEE A BRAND-NEW
MEDIA CENTER RESEARCH STUDY
REVEALING THAT OUT OF A HUNDRED
AND 15 ELECTION STORIES OUT OF
ABC, CBS, NBC, 87% TREATED
REPUBLICANS NEGATIVELY DESPITE
DEMOCRATS BEING THE PILE
DEMOCRAT PARTY IN POWER OF
COURSE.
MY NEXT GUEST IS THE ONLY ONE
WHO RECEIVED ZERO POSITIVE
STORIES ACCORDING TO THE STUDY.
A HUNDRED PERCENT OF THE
COVERAGE ABOUT KERRY LAKE FROM
THE BIG THREE NETWORKS WAS
NEGATIVE.
DESPITE THAT, LAKE IS STILL UP
BY NEARLY THREE IN THE MOST
RECENT RCP AVERAGE.
SHE JOINS ME NOW.
KERRY, IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
THIS IS HISTORICALLY FUNNY IN
ONE WAY, AND IN ANOTHER WAY IT'S
VERY DEPRESSING.
BUT HOW ARE YOU COPING WITH THE
NEWS THAT THE COVERAGE HAS BEEN
A HUNDRED PERCENT NEGATIVE?
DO YOU NEED A FRUIT BASKET OR
ANY KIND OF SECURITY BLANKET TO
GET YOURSELF THROUGH THIS
DIFFICULT TIME?
>> I NEED A SAFE SPACE AND AN
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT ANIMAL TO GET
THROUGH IT.
I'M IN A WHERE IT IS OF HONOR,
TRULY, THAT THE FAKE NEWS MEDIA
SEES THIS MOVEMENT OF MAMA BEARS
OUT HERE IN ARIZONA AS SUCH A
THREAT TO THEIR AGENDA THAT
THEY'RE RUNNING A HUNDRED
PERCENT NEGATIVE STORIES ON ME.
THE AMAZING THING IS JUST
REVEALING THAT THEY'VE LOST
THEIR POWER.
IF THEY'RE PUTTING A HUNDRED
PERCENT NEGATIVE STORIES ON ME,
AND THE LAST POLL I SAW SHOWED
US UP BY 11, I DON'T LIKE IT'S
WORKING ANYMORE.
THE PEOPLE ARE AWAKE TO THE
GARBAGE THAT THE PEDDLING.
>> Laura: YOUR OPPONENT MADE A
RECENT COMMENT THAT I THOUGHT I
WOULD SHARE.
WATCH.
>> WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY TO VOTERS EVERY SINGLE
DAY, IT'S ONE OF THE TOP
CONCERNS.
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE PLANS WE
HAVE TO ACTUALLY ADDRESS
INFLATION.
KERRY LAKE DOESN'T HAVE AN
ECONOMIC PLAN THAT DOES ANYTHING
EXCEPT MAKE INFLATION WORSE.
>> Laura: I MUST'VE MISSED ALL
THOSE TOWN HALLS ON THE ECONOMY
THAT KATIE HOBBS DID.
WAS SHE TALKING ABOUT?
>> FOR SMALL HER TAX PLAN, WHICH
THE FAKE NEWS COVERED AS IF IT
WAS THE GREATEST THING EVER,
IT'S ABOUT TAKING AND REMOVING
THAT TAX OFF OF DIAPERS AND
FEMININE HYGIENE PRODUCTS.
THAT'S GREAT BUT WE'VE GOT A GO
BETTER AND FARTHER THAN THAT.
MY TAX PLAN, MY INFLATION RELIEF
FOR THE HARDWORKING PEOPLE OF
ARIZONA, AS YOU GET RID OF OUR
GROCERY TAX AND THE TAX WE PAN
RENTS, RENTING AN APARTMENT OR
HOME.
THOSE ARE TWO AREAS THAT WILL
HELP THE BOTTOM LINE FOR
HARDWORKING ARIZONANS AND PEOPLE
WHO ARE STRUGGLING RIGHT NOW,
AND THAT'LL PUT A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IMMEDIATELY BACK INTO
THE POCKETS OF ARIZONA CITIZENS.
WE CAN GO EVEN FURTHER BY
CUTTING TAXES EVERY YEAR
INCLUDING SALES TAX, PROPERTY
TAX, WILL TRY TO TRIM DOWN THE
INCOME TAX AS WELL.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE A PLAN.
HER PLAN IS BASICALLY WHATEVER
JOE BIDEN IS DOING.
IT'S JOE BIDEN AND HIS TERRIBLE
ECONOMIC POLICIES THAT HAVE
GOTTEN US INTO THIS
HYPERINFLATION AND METS WERE IN
NOW.
IT'LL TAKE SOME STRONG
REPUBLICANS TO GET US OUT.
>> Laura: THEY KEEP GIVING ME
SPEECHES ABOUT THE DEMOCRACY
BEING THREATENED BY REPUBLICANS,
THEN YOU HAD MALLORCA'S OUT,
DHS'S ACHIEVE TALKING ABOUT THE
BORDER DO IT AGAIN NOT
CONNECTING ON THE ISSUE.
I WANT TO BITE AND GET YOUR
REACTION.
>> THERE ARE A NUMBER OF FORCES
THAT ARE FUELING VIOLENT
EXTREMISM.
IDEOLOGIES OF HATE, FALSE
NARRATIVES, ANTIGOVERNMENT
SENTIMENT, PERSONAL GRIEVANCES.
THEN THE DIVISIVENESS IN THIS
COUNTRY IS OF GREAT CONCERN.
>> Laura: CARRY, CLEARLY THERE
IS AN ATTEMPT TO CRIMINALIZE THE
POLITICAL OPPOSITION HERE.
THEY'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
INDIVIDUAL ACTS OF VIOLENCE
WHICH WILL CONDEMN AND WE ALL
ABSOLUTELY THINK A
REPREHENSIBLE, WHOEVER'S
CARRYING THEM OUT.
THIS IS REALLY AN EFFORT TO
OSTRACIZE, DEMONIZE, AND ALTER
THE MIGHT ULTIMATELY CANCEL THE
ENTIRE CONSERVATIVE MOVEMENT.
WHAT BIDEN IS TALKING ABOUT IS
THE SELECTION DENIER NEGATIVITY
AND ALL OF THAT.
YOUR REACTION?
>> THEY'RE TRYING TO KEEP US
FROM SPEAKING OUT AS PEOPLE ARE
WAKING UP TO THE LIES.
THE TRYING TO GET US TO BE
QUIET.
I AM OF THE SUMMER OF 2020 THERE
WAS A LOT OF VIOLENCE IN THE
STREETS.
THE LEFT WAS IN SPEAKING OUT
AGAINST CHURCHES BEING BURNED IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., PORTLAND BEING
RIGHTED AND BUILDINGS BURNING,
IN BLUE CITIES, LIBERAL CITIES.
I DON'T REMEMBER THEM SPEAKING
OUT AGAINST THAT VIOLENCE.
I'M OPPOSED TO VIOLENCE OF ANY
KIND.
I WISH HE WOULD ACTUALLY DO HIS
JOB AND WORK TO STOP THE FLOW OF
ILLEGALS COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
WE DON'T KNOW WHO THESE PEOPLE
ARE, WE KNOW MANY OF THEM HAVE
RECORDS.
AND IT'S HURTING OUR COUNTRY.
I REALLY WISH SHE WOULD GET ON
THAT INSTEAD OF TRYING TO STOKE
POLITICAL AGITATION ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY AND MAKE THINGS WORSE
AND MORE DIVIDED.
>> Laura: THE CROWD OF
VENEZUELANS THAT RUSHED THE
BORDER YESTERDAY WAS HORRIFIC.
LIVES ARE BEING PUT IN DANGER.
THIS IS ALSO PLAYING INTO THE
SHIFT AMONG WOMEN VOTERS,
ESPECIALLY SUBURBAN WOMEN
VOTERS.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" PULLED
THAT CAME OUT SAID THAT THE
G.O.P. HAS SEEN A SHIFT AMONG
WHITE SUBURBAN WOMEN.
THAT GROUPS SHIFTED 26
PERCENTAGE POINTS AWAY FROM THE
DEMOCRATS SENSE THAT JOURNALS
AUGUST POLL.
WHITE SUBURBAN WINNER BACK WOMEN
BY 15 PERCENTAGE POINTS.
WHAT DO YOU ATTRIBUTE THAT?
>> I SAW LAST NIGHT, WE HOLD BIG
EVENTS EVERY DAY, BETWEEN SIX
AND TEN MEETINGS AND EVENTS EACH
DAY.
LAST NIGHT WE HAD A WONDERFUL
RALLY, IT WAS PACKED WITH
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE.
SO MANY OF THEM WERE MOMS.
I CALL THEM MY MAMA BEARS.
WHEN I WENT AND TALKED TO THEM,
WE WERE TAKING PICTURES IN THE
CROWD AND TALKING ABOUT HOW
WORRIED WE ARE ABOUT OUR
CHILDREN IN THE FUTURE.
THAT'S WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
MOMS WANT SAFE STREETS.
THEY WANT TO FULLY FUND OUR
POLICE DEPARTMENTS SO THAT THEY
KNOW CRIME IS KEPT LOW.
WHEN THEY CALL 911 THEY WANT TO
KNOW THEY CAN GET HELP.
THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
BORDER IS SECURE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T WANT FENTANYL COMING
ACROSS AND GETTING INTO THE
HANDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND THEY WANT EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
GET TRADE SCHOOL TRAINING,
VOCATIONAL TRAINING, OR CAREER
CERTIFICATION IN HIGH SCHOOL SO
THEY'RE READY FOR THE REAL JOBS
OUT THERE.
HE'S A PRINCE MY PLATFORM.
I THINK THAT'S WEATHER WITH US.
AND THEY ALSO KNOW THAT THEY
WANT SOMEONE WHO'S GOING TO
PROTECT THEIR KIDS FROM THESE
NEW FOREST SHOTS THAT THE CDC IS
RECOMMENDING AN ORDER FOR OUR
CHILDREN TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
SCHOOL.
I SPOKE OUT IMMEDIATELY AND SAID
WE'LL NEVER MAKE OUR KIDS
GUINEA PIGS, WE WILL NEVER FORCE
THOSE SHOTS ON OUR CHILDREN.
OUR OPPONENT, WHEN ASKED IF SHE
WOULD FORCE OUR KIDS TO GET
THOSE EXPERIMENTAL SHOTS, HER
ANSWER WAS.
I DON'T KNOW.
I HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT IT.
THIS IS WHETHER VOTING FOR US IN
RECORD NUMBERS.
>> Laura: FREEDOM, SAFETY,
COMMON SENSE.
KERRY LAKE, YOU'RE SUPPRESSING A
LOT OF PEOPLE OUT THERE AND I
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE WHAT PLAYS OUT
ON TUESDAY NIGHT.
WE'LL BE WATCHING.
IF WE DO